[Music]
all right so the guy we have now right
he's a pretty Pablo you do where he
didn't it who did an impression of us
cute right let's go to steven crowder
we're glad you there
wait I'm sorry yeah I have you on for
for a sound check now
Stephen I think I'll be back on James
okay we're live right of course
we're live you know Jay Jay come on okay
so come on I'm sorry I have you down as
a sound check treatment obly I think
I'll be here okay jag where's the guest
where's the guys the guys should be here
that was that was literally like 30
seconds ago he's like they're Armenian
Genocide Jenkins
[Music]
no no bacon grease today you need
balance
[Music]
let's take a bad turn quickly okay I
don't want to get mad right so I'll take
five minutes
Xena's shaving mana break you're
invading my privacy you
you've found yourself at the junction
where worlds meet politics civility
how about honesty in this country folks
entertainment and a whole bunch of other
stuff without having a healthy body
image you've a very unhealthy body you
should have a horrible body in not a big
home of food market New Jersey we are
definitely going to get letters you're
listening to talk radio strangest animal
[Music]
you're getting louder with Crowder
[Music]
glad to be with you that's the sound of
the weekend people were asking me before
I make my mic here adjusted I'm your
host even credit ladder with credit comm
for all references and materials
producing with me in video studio as
always as Jared who is not gay follow
him on Twitter at not gay Jared I
fulfilled my lead my legal obligations
and you can draw your own conclusions
references are so old school by the way
we make the stuff I make the stuff up on
the fly we got a big show huge show
young so we have big debate with Sally
Kohn yep I know people are going to get
mad I actually have a lot of respect for
Sally she's willing to get into
conversations with voices of opposition
Sally Kohn Andrew Klavan talking about
Hillary Clinton and Anthony ku Mia
probably talking about Hillary Clinton
as well mm-hmm later on and we also have
Hillary Clinton there so that's a good
that's a big get that's what I call a
big catch it is I'm surprised you know
it's heavy-duty fishing line mm-hmm
deep-sea you need like a shark chair yes
but we did we reeled in Hillary Clinton
we caught her she's going to be in the
second hour or for those listen to the
podcasts and YouTube somewhere in the
hour-and-a-half mark and Bob Ross joins
us again to teach you how to draw
Hillary Clinton Wow because I'm
wondering what should we start off with
Hillary Clinton or the the Tyree King
Tyree King thing is uh blown up deal
okay so we'll get nailer cutting because
there's a lot that's happened this week
the DNC leaks Hillary Clinton is now
statistically tied with Donald Trump
that is insanity not really anything can
happen it's still anybody's game but
they're probably hitting panic button or
just stabbing each other with the
diazepam pen who knows what their panic
but all the saying is Tyree King was
trending today this is another one in
the black lives matter number one trend
all over the place
listen you hear this at first glance and
it it sounds terrible thirteen-year-old
kid shot by police officer you're going
oh no but that's not what happened so
it's all over Twitter let me let me tell
you something here beyond with a
situation like this well okay
we don't any video with Terry King do we
know he's had this you have an image we
have some images let me give you some
context so it sounds horrible thirteen
year old shot by police officers until
you realize that the officer was
approaching him because he was he was
fingered from someone at 2:00 a.m.
armed robbery with a firearm police
officer approached him and some friends
his other friends ran then this boy also
ran into an alley and he pulled out when
apprehended by the police officers
pulled his BB gun that looks like a real
gun from his waistband just so there's
no confusion beyond the obvious that
it's always sad when there's a loss of
human life to some degree beyond that
I've reached a point where I have no
sympathy left to give committing a
violent crime and pulling a gun out or
whatever looks it looks exactly like a
gun on an officer at 2:00 a.m. at your
age is irrelevant
your race is irrelevant you're rolling
the dice and you lost that one let's
bring up the image here this is the
police officer okay so there's the 13
year old kid there's a firearm you don't
want to notice right away when I saw
that firearm that's that's the BB gun
for those listening to arrest it looks
exactly like a real gun proof here you
go here is my I love this firearm by the
way Walther PPQ Jared can we do a splits
go at me and then or no probably not no
can alright there you go you can't know
you can't know at 2:00 a.m. you cannot
know it 2:00 a.m. that that's not a real
firearm so this idea that cops two cops
are shooting kids for her first court
guns it's it's silly and it's irrelevant
the cop thought that it was an actual
firearm and this idea came out that well
they wouldn't do this with a white kid
right because I know that when I was a
kid and I committed violent assault what
I robbed people when I committed armed
robbery and when I pulled my BB gun out
on police officers I said thank thank
God for white supremacy yes but again
were you not taught as a kid don't even
aim a nerf gun at a police officer yeah
before that was don't commit armed
robberies at 280 that was a big one you
go at lunchtime you right you go last
time you have to pick your spot yeah so
this idea right away is black lives
matter they could have shot him with a
beanbag gun right they're gonna walk it
you may be thinking it you know what
let's just let's just armed police
officers with t-shirt cannons like you
see at baseball games just hey one of
those the Crips hope you want a Cancun
booze cruise t-shirt I have yet to win
one of those teach in my whole life yeah
disappointing tone down the power Lea BP
was in beanbag gun shoot the kid in 11
those are lethal too well yours here's
how these things get completely
conflated right shoot why don't you
shoot Nick hit in the leg it wasn't a
violent threat that Officer thinks
that's a real gun he has to act as if it
is it's the most absurd story and it
Koren gains this is a great example when
black lives matter trotty's out they're
almost always folks now let's assume
that the police reports are somewhat
accurate right away what do they say if
you look at the tweets we covered this
on the website oh oh you're supposed to
believe the neo-nazi KKK police when you
say this this is what we're seeing
record violence against the police
officers when you hold this out and you
you have to Shaun King the narrative
with 13 year old innocent kid just has a
has a cap gun and gets shot by police
officer for no reason listen you think
those officers are monsters and so you
make it okay to treat them like monsters
this is what you have we don't have any
more on that do we on our as the images
no we have to be your Shaun King this is
just like Tamir rice the kid who was
shot for playing than a playground
anyone have you seen the Tamir rice
video here we'll roll it for you this is
the Tamir rice video that's him aiming
what looks like a real gun at passers-by
in the park so even there in a hoodie
you can't give me rice as the golden
example they point to he wasn't asked
did he deserve to die
no is it unfortunate yeah is it
something that that was entirely
preventable absolutely this is going to
happen it's going to happen more and
more especially as it goes into election
you're going to hear more stories of
sexism we have a video on that from now
what's your name Veronica Mars Kristen
Bell later where we're going to have to
go back to dispelling the pay gap myth
again you're gonna see more of these
leading up to election because this is
what what Democrats need odn see leaks
happen better ask
pence about David Duke Hillary Clinton
had an epileptic seizure better let's
let's put out a story of a kid being
shot by officer
I'm a bird you only see more of these
stories of racism of sexism stories that
that basically create that narrative or
at least support it you're going to see
far far more of that so we covered on
the website it's not what it looks out
what it seems at first pass that's what
matters what the the Lehrer
teary what's-his-name Tyree King Tyree
Tyree also a silly name it's a silly
name it there's no there there's no
reason there's no meaning to it no I
don't know what what it is with with
black Americans is like if you want to
go with your African hair just pick pick
a name or name that means something in
English my [ __ ] erases grandfather
always said they just took a yeah scarce
categories dice know God just see what
you're a horrible human being so this is
before the show of course everyone knows
about the and we'll be talking about
this we're going to have Hillary Clinton
on to discuss her health later because
this is the famous clip from from this
week it happened quite a while ago in
the week Jared you can just roll the
clip there's no sound there here you go
you can see Hillary Clinton and there
you go she's she's bracing her fat
immobile hips against that thing there
and she's just okay alright just so you
know we never covered this is important
for people listening right now this is
this is pulling back the curtain
we never covered the conspiratorial
hillary health issues right we never
really got into him people saying oh she
clearly has parkinson's because it's not
something that we know right it's not
something that can be verified this we
did cover we were first to cover it in
when it happened Sunday morning we got
to it really early because there's
something going on here okay and they
lied about it that's what matters now
we'll tell you this be leery when you
read about Hillary health stories
because when we ran this story it did
about four times the clicks of any other
story from that week so Hillary health
conspiracies are like catnip for clicks
and so you see a lot of conservative lot
of right-wing sites trying to make more
money off of it and they push it when
it's not true this is the only one we
actively covered so it's important to be
truthful with it and that's why this one
is such a story they said she had
pneumonia here's the deal they lied
about it they lied about Hillary's
health and you see it by the way
pneumonia would it doesn't look I've
known many people with pneumonia
had bronchitis it doesn't look like that
um they lied about it they could have
just done a Friday hey Hillary Clinton's
diagnosed with pneumonia she's going to
be out of the campaign for the weekend
she needs some rest instead they were
saying oh these right-wing conspiracy
there's Hillary is in perfect health
she's a picture of health never mind her
doing the Carlton dance yes of mine her
doing the Carlton dance and then this
happened so why it matters now is it it
could it be that she has pneumonia yes
of course that's probably the most
likely scenario however could it also be
that her campaign lied proactively
because that's just what they do that's
Tuesday
that's Friday that's any day all days
are lying days with the Hillary Clinton
campaign so they just lied because I
didn't know what else to do
yeah so it's very likely she has
something like pneumonia I think there's
something more going on here if you
watch that video and of course your
campaign is lying about the kids the
kaga can we talk about this Lomb lying
is bad enough that's bad enough
that's bad enough that's bad enough yeah
that you don't need to do the body
double conspiracies and you don't the
Republicans can snatch defeat from the
jaws of victory words like Leslie Browns
yes every day they lied about this let's
go with that well also she she's a
lizard person damn it but this all comes
back to something plausible Hillary
Clinton I have this up on my screen is
now in a statistical tie with Donald
Trump the lead she had has had has
narrowed greatly she's still ahead by
the RCP average particularly in in a
head-to-head with a four-person race
it's a tie well this also comes in the
heels of the DNC leaks I have this up
here well you know we'll get into that
more after the break and Americans trust
in mass media has sunken to a new low
all-time low according to Gallup so all
this happens at the same time Hillary is
now in a tie the DNC leaks the health
issues listen there have been leaks
going on for a long time there have been
a lot of people asking questions
regarding her health dr. Drew was fired
for asking questions about Hillary
Clinton's health and now it comes out
it's true
DNC leaks now it comes out that there's
been collusion corruption beyond the
scope of what we even thought and
Hillary's in a statistical tie so it's
not just the fact that she's sick it's
not just the fact that the race is
narrowing it is a reflection of what
people are thinking regarding Hillary
Clinton in the Democratic Party and I
think that's pretty significant so we'll
get into DNC leaks and a little economic
sir this boys fun brainy
[Music]
ah now for The Adventures of the white
privilige boy
[Music]
hey buddies what do you want to do today
you you want to go down to the arcade
and play pinball I know how about we
play hide-and-seek last week I know want
to take our accurate to replica BB guns
and commit an armed robbery let's do it
yeah all those boys what pickle will
they find themselves in next stay tuned
for next week's installment of
adventures of the white privilege boys
hey Jared
what are you doing shooting bad guys
with what - where'd you get it
pfft Nakai I'm on state it more clearly
so our audience can hear ar-15 calm
that's better
they sell guns now yeah they do are they
any good
they're the best we're from air 15 akan
Kapoor come I should really make that
sound didn't have the budget for side of
bag with wipe air 15 from where Fatima
calm how do you know they're bad guys
Debra's in burkas that's racist
[Music]
glad to be back have Sally cone coming
up here at the end of this segment
so DNC Leakes came out and boy was that
buried quickly boy was that buried
quickly from social media um what do we
know about DNC leaks I have this up on
the screen we know that there have been
mammoth donations to the DNC from hey
surprise any sector of the government
whether it's the post office any sectors
that have involves public sector unions
all of them give massive lead to
Democrats not only that do they give
massively to Democrats but we've found
out that Democrats were providing a
favors and positions on boards for these
people so for example any folks who
you'd like to be considered to be on the
board of for example USPS any a neh
basically anyone who has a niche
interest and might like to serve on one
of these organizations this is of course
being delivered to donors there so we've
always known that the Democrats were
corrupt this is just a whole new level
of it this is one thing they've talked
about science research basically any
information from with which you're
provided from the government of course
can be manipulated here's something
that's funny when people say all big oil
big companies there is nothing that can
create the kind of corruption and
collusion that the government can look
at Wall Street that's government that's
not just Walt that cannot exist without
government because banks that are too
big to fail guess what they fail too big
to fail as a government problem not a
bank problem so by the way the top
political donors of the donating
political class it's big unions
particularly big public sector unions so
when people say oh you're just providing
research all at Saturno against climate
change because of Big Oil well there are
billions and unpaid tax cut liabilities
from green companies and scientists have
billions of dollars in research now
these are scientists who work for the
government so not only are they
incentivized like people who maybe work
for private business they are beholden
they are required to find a reason for
the DNC to be in power and bigger
government otherwise those grants stop
when people act like this gravy train is
coming from these private companies in
our debt just hit nineteen point five
trillion nineteen point five trillion
just a few billion dollars in tax
liabilities with green companies that
have been on
to Obama Solyndra was 500 million can
you imagine if there were one private
company that had five hundred million
dollars of taxpayer money that they
wouldn't give back one company one
company with billions it would be your
discovery that the Koch the Koch
brothers what I worked a few billion
people get mad about pillar were three
billion dollars the government is
nineteen point five trillion and a lot
of that money goes to coaxing people not
to mention we're talking about the post
office here they're bankrupt yeah you
know they're Cuban millions you know
could use some funding I think this
needs a little funding oh my god ah it's
too early in the program for that not
gauge I'd put up a summative Lena Dunham
in a bikini anyway that's that's a brief
lesson economic something else how much
time do we have we have five minutes
yeah for now four and a half this is
important so people talk about their
fair share you know we might want to
take more yeah okay we'll talk about
this the top fifth of earners in the
United States and people talk about
their Fisher I have this up on here I've
increased their income from forty three
percent in nineteen seventy nine to
forty eight percent in 2010 the top one
percent of increase their share and for
nineteen seventy nine from eight percent
to 13 percent so when people say you're
not getting your fair share that's what
they're talking about here's the deal
everyone is doing far better so why do
you'll understand this inequality is not
the main issue if everyone is doing
better if some people are doing far
better let me give you an example a lot
of was credit didn't exist two years ago
I told Jared he was pushing a salt truck
I said hey Jared this is what I can pay
you it's not a lot but as we grow I
promise you I'll pay you more now we
have five employees and Jared gets a far
smaller share of a much bigger pie so
let me give you an example what would
you rather have here here's Jared before
a lot orth credit two years ago I'm
giving you some visual aids here he had
at least half the AIDS of the full pie I
took no salaries dear nose and the rest
went into marketing and growth and
serving costs okay so Jared had half of
that pie that's more fair well here's
the new pie with many more employees
forgive the the oblong pie now Jared has
this share of the pie so if your
worldview is just well there's one piece
of pie and you need your fair share well
guess what that first pie is better
because Jared has half he only has a
quarter of this new pie even though the
quarter is
w can see the size of the very first pie
and this is why it matters so this is
why this matters because yeah every
situation needs to be taken individually
you need to look at issues critically
and there is nuance but isms matter when
people think that they're above ago I'm
not a conservative I'm not a liberal I
don't believe in isms no no the ISM is
the prism through which you will see the
world and if you believe in liberalism
or leftism you would look at Jared
situation let's say he's making $1,000 a
month you look at that at 50% said well
here's the pie that's his share that's
fair whereas conservatism says well hold
on we want to increase this pie so that
he can make five six seven thousand
dollars a month whatever it is even
though he'll be making a smaller slice
of the overall pie that pie from
thousands goes to millions now the ISM
is do you see the economy as a fixed pie
as a fixed size and everyone is getting
their piece ironically enough socialism
that leftist view is very selfish it's
very hopeless right or and it also
creates an entitlement mindset because
if you think there's only so much to go
around I better get my slice or the ISM
conservatism federalism do you see the
economy do you see the world as a living
breathing growing ecosystem that thrives
with innovation with creativity with
hard work if you see it that way you're
not so worried about will I need my
percentage a period I need to get mine
you're thinking men how can I grow this
piece of how can I grow this pie for
everybody well enough all of a sudden
you're looking at the best interest of
everybody
the bigger the pie for everybody else
the better you do whereas in socialism
leftism you just want your piece you're
not thinking you you can't even have
brain storage for this idea that you
could possibly grow it and that's what's
so important and that's what the Bernie
people don't get and that's what young
leftists don't get get yours get your
piece no go out there and create more
pus if you look at the GDP if you look
at how bigger how much bigger the
economy is it's unbelievable who cares
if you have a percentage that's fair if
you're making 10 times as much if you're
helping 10 times as many people that's
why the ISM matters it doesn't mean that
you should be dogmatic I hate any kind
of dogmatic thinking but you do have to
have a baseline filter through which you
run issues in the world if you're just
looking at everything going well ok I
guess that seems fair
well what why isn't that good you're
only getting 20 why is only getting 10%
if he was getting 15% well what would
you rather have would you have 50% of
$10,000 or would you rather have 10% of
a million dollars I'm using extreme
numbers to make a point but that's how
companies grow that's how economies grow
and the ISM is important the first
filter it goes through needs to be okay
how do I view the world and that'll
change everything also there's one
that's in line with actual economics uh
Sally Cohen after this speaking of
debate that'll be fun it'll be fun be
fun
[Music]
now it's time to play America's favorite
game show spot the firearm the rules are
simple one of these images is a real
firearm the other is a BB gun replica
you have precisely five seconds to guess
which one is real are you ready let's go
[Applause]
and your partner's dead
[Music]
all right glad to be back glad to have
this next guest and everyone's going to
say what are you trying to do it to be
polite no I've known her for a while we
were at Fox News at the same time we
disagree on nearly everything but she's
a gamer
she's trait she stands in the pocket and
she trades you can follow her on Twitter
she's a CNN contributor at Sally Kohn
koh n thank you for being here I think
we probably actually in truth agree on
more than we disagree we just disagree
on the political things everybody fights
about well I think I'm you know versus
Pepsi right what do you think I don't
drink either but my wife swears that
Pepsi is an invention Oh Satan Pepsi
coke but my in-laws family they're all
big pets people so I'm sort of say
publicly politics but you know I mean
like before we get into politics is a
perfect example of little young sister
yes
no little young skeptical Steven was we
had the pit really did the Pepsi
challenge that was a marketing ploy I
was a Grand Bend Ontario I wasn't even a
teenager and they did this down there in
the beach and I go ho so here's a which
one do you prefer
that's look at him I go I prefer the one
that you iced first they got one I got
one that was more more than what's
called them I guess the ice one was
Pepsi and they're like okay move it
along kid and sleepovers doing the Coke
Pepsi challenge like for fun with
friends I mean you know this is before
the internet kids and then one of them
just if you just don't play with Bill
Cosby that's the general challenge
people get mad with a rape joke the bill
cosby'd Cosby drugs people joke so okay
let's talk about a few things so we
wanted to have you on for a while
obviously I have been very much at the
forefront coming from Quebec coming from
a school with a lot of Muslims against
Islam the theology the philosophy period
yes
not all Muslims Islam just like atheists
are against no not all Muslims but isn't
particularly Mohammed now you wrote a
piece
and I want to make sure that I don't
misrepresent you so I want you to say it
in your own words you had a piece you
wrote a piece on Sharia law you get a
lot of backlash saying that Donald Trump
is misrepresenting a lot of Muslims that
there are a lot of progressives who
support Sharia law there are progressive
versions of Sharia law am I getting that
wrong because you know I do think words
matter right so Sharia the concept of
Sharia right and by the way let's just
start right here and people can be like
well why are you talking about this well
because I do think it's our job to you
know educate ourselves and learn as much
as we can and my understanding on this
has evolved as a you know liberal Jew I
didn't grow up knowing much about Islam
right I have tried to learn and so
Sharia as a concept is is about faith is
about beliefs it's the whole spiritual
code of Islam there is no and it
includes everything from giving to
charity to praying you know three times
a day to you know not eating certain
things that this and that the other by
the way there's no one version of
Islamic beliefs or what it means to be a
good Muslim written down it's not just
one single version of it there's all
different URP rotational things there
are there aren't a number there are four
schools of Sharia law they're about four
and two main ones so let's we can get
into like okay now there's this you know
version of Sharia and there's this
version three simple point is is and I
cite the example in the article that my
progressive feminist lesbian Muslim
friend so a secular Muslim believes in
so a secular Muslim wears a hijab she
observes Ramadan she I mean she believes
in Sharia in a version of Sharia and so
the the only point there is is when you
know folks on the right saying what we
should ban all Muslims who believe in
quote-unquote Sharia well you I mean
depending on how you define your terms
right second so so I agree with you
words matter so we're talking about
Sharia law that's what we're talking
about now you can talk about Sharia and
talk about how it
you know some people misconstrue it as a
personal path but there are two things
when you get into the pragmatic and
we'll get into that into countries that
implement any kind of Sharia law and
then the philosophical but to say that
Sharia has historically been interpreted
as like people try to say with Islam it
needs submission it's about a personal
struggle or jihad no jihad has very
clearly been interpreted as a very
physical war whether some people talk
about an internal struggle jihad and
Sharia law is something where we have
enough legal precedent you can look to
any country in the world right now any
country that implements Sharia law and
you can even look to countries in the
you can email up to the UK you can look
to Europe where anywhere it's
implemented it has been a net negative
universally for human rights would we
agree on that I mean let's let's be
super clear on something here I am
against any version iteration
incarnation moral legal conceptual
theological of Islam that calls for the
oppression of women the you know
condemnation of gay people and the you
know putting of one faith over and I
mean oh by the way I'm against that is
that is always long doesn't mean all of
them are throwing gays off roof doesn't
mean they're all plastic it doesn't mean
are all beating their wives but by your
own standards by your own standards at
you apply to Christians that is all
Islam as far as women are not treated
well gay people are not treated well
even the most modern interpretations of
Sharia law are gross violations of human
rights
so let's first I can put Sharia law as a
concept and again by the way you know
you want to go down the wormhole this
their whole debates about because again
there's no like you can't go find the
Sharia law book Constitution all these
school of thought and yet the Maliki
school of thought so you can look at the
worst like the Mahankali where you look
at Saudi Arabia a lot of these Gulf
states and even other country to harness
that this really matters
there's consistent application
everywhere everywhere Sharia laws
implemented there is a book on it
Abdullah he al Nayeem who's the foremost
scholar on the practice and
implementation of Sharia law around the
water and if you talk to him he'll say
look there's 50 different versions of it
because even the school that says you
know we're practicing this version will
they leave it Kasich but this is what
mattered it matters when you look
anywhere your Islamic no Han this
matters it matters anywhere you look
that there's Islamic government okay
anywhere that you looks like there is
Islamic government based on Sharia
anywhere in the world can we at least
it's bad it's something that we should
not even remotely except in the United
States okay so this is important now are
you also aware that every single mosque
can act as a Sharia Court because you've
written about this in your column
they can't have a mosque exist if there
isn't an imam who's there who is capable
of performing sharia law that's
important I understand where you're
going here's the issue I'm having I have
no problem agreeing with you strongly
that a the implementation of any version
of a right-wing totalitarian
misogynistic homophobic there's nothing
right-wing about about totalitarian
Islamic regimes okay whatever you want
to whatever you want to use on against
okay
okay but we both know that's not there's
nothing right-wing about Isis or Turkey
or Egypt or Malaysia or Morocco and you
those moderate place nothing right-wing
about them very far very far left in
their application of government and
overbearing government that's
fascinating okay I'm call them
fundamentalist so I would call them if
you want to call them modern girls
traditionalist you want to go in that
direct I want to make it clear so Sally
cone agrees with me I tend to think of
as regressive I can note with a more
conservative ideology but whatever so
you agree with me that every single
Islamic country in the world has a
regressive fundamentalist system of law
maybe one that doesn't one that doesn't
one example this is important for gonna
talk about Sharia one country that has a
Sharia law example that you would be
okay with you're doing this thing can we
just stick with one thing at a time can
we just do that for me cuz cuz my brain
isn't as big as yours so give me a
second here the one thing one real quick
free debt you've waited into an audience
who's much more intelligent than the
average cable news viewers so you do it
a little wordplay is not going to work
especially they have a rewind button
smart I'm happy right and again bearing
in mind I'm not the expert on Islamic
theology nor Islamic States nor frankly
being a Muslim cuz I'm not one right so
what you wrote about it here's here's
where I'm stuck huh we can go then talk
about the difference between Tunisia and
Morocco and you know Indonesia as
opposed to Saudi Arabia which i think is
a horrible state that the United States
should never been supporting and we can
talk about the nuances in between how
can you do that I'm still confused
mm-hmm though as to how you can't say
okay the problem is fundamentalist Islam
extremist Islam that it's a problem and
you get from there to all Muslims what
do you do who I described as a
progressive feminist game was gonna
answer your question we should support
can answer your question okay um I'm not
nearly as concerned with a radical
outlier in a feminist lesbian Muslim
girl who wears a hijab I am concerned
with every place in the history of the
world Sharia law hasn't implemented
where it exists today what's happening
in Europe and what's happening in
mosques across the United State this is
not radicalism this is not
fundamentalism you wrote in your piece I
want to bring up your own words because
it's important you wrote that they can
have their own courts in their mosques
provided it doesn't supersede the
Constitution it is incompatible with our
current system of rights in the United
States do you know what happens in a
Shareef I didn't actually write okay go
on well you wrote that like Jewish law
like Jewish lar different different
Christian courts you heard about they
settle disputes domestic you would be
against it this you would be for
deporting Hassan Hassan cuz I've got it
right here in front me this is really
important this is important it is not
fundamentalism where this occurs at
every single mosque across the country
is it fundamentalism that Mohammed beat
his wife their founder is it
fundamentalism that he called the deaths
of Christians and Jews is that
fundamentalism because that's my problem
right back with Mohammed so Stephen
there are fundamentalist I'm Jewish
there are I live in New York City there
are fundamentalist
whatever we're going to use
fundamentalist more conservative small C
conservative conventional you know
traditionalist Jews
in New York City I'm from the United
States who believe that I am a sinner
who would like to see you know legal if
not physical punishment imposed on me
for being gay I am against that I am
offended by that I am any number of
things about that don't want to see him
deported that's not that's not
mainstream Judaism it's the difference
between curly sideburns and bombs here's
my confusion which is first of all I can
agree with you that there needs to be a
broader Reformation in Islam and by the
way that's why we should be supporting
well under not millions of Muslims who
support apostasy laws who support
spousal abuse laws second of all see but
you're the reason you get those argument
you get those conclusions from assuming
that they mean by Sharia what you mean
by Sharia which was no no no I'm saying
this matters this matters matters Sally
you're you're calling you're jumping all
around on individual issues these
Muslims say yes I should pull support
Sharia and then in addendum hundreds of
millions of Muslims say I support
apostasy laws
I support anti-homosexuality laws
hundreds of millions of Muslims stop
horsin Hassan
could it be could it would it stand to
reason that if hundreds of millions of
Muslims a majority of Muslims support
Sharia in some fashion or another and
then hundreds of millions of Muslims say
we support apostasy laws we support
spousal abuse laws would it stand to
reason that maybe that would be a not
radical and be directly tied to their
support for Sharia hundreds of millions
undeniable support these individual laws
my own concern is Stephen so 900 million
see you so first of all let's yeah we
won't actually pull out the Pew poll
data that you're talking about and go
blind by line and refute some of that
first of all that's fine but again you
brought up Jews or Christians there
aren't hundreds of millions of Jews who
support those if there are there are
tens of millions of Muslims in this
country if they are all if you as what
you just said is true if the notion that
they are all peaceful that they are
majority peaceful peace-loving moderate
human beings if that's an aberration
which is what you said let's to me it
was like yeah well a couple is it does
happen all the time and I think you
lowered bar for them because you have a
much higher standard of Christians which
you would consider a violation of Rights
and Muslims would be far worse but I
want to keep you on we have to go to
this break for a corporate overlords
Sally cone we appreciate her standing in
the pocket and coming on we'll be right
back
be right back
[Music]
[Music]
okay so this next segment we're excited
right before the guests he's a longtime
fan of the show remember the Wolfpack
sargon of akkad re there I wouldn't so
much say a fan I mean maybe I used to be
but then you kind of declared kind of
everything was racist and then I was
looking back and you were saying like
everything was racist back then as well
and I'm thinking why did I ever watch
you guys okay right this is what he's
trying to do he's trying to sandbag
where he comes this well I would want
that fab until you sits up the graces of
course you're always all the longtime
fat before beauty
but I've been really trying to diet yeah
we'll try harder I'm better than you
well study me you brexit Inge Infowars
right go back to it for Wars turn down
by year we have an image ok view with a
racist sign sir guarded [ __ ] that's
not even me
that's clearly a Photoshop and it's not
how Bolan
maybe you tool time looking fat
are you are you body shaming me facial
seaming you don't even mean you know
your shame whatever takes the attention
of you must die sweetheart ok that's it
so maybe a delay without mustaches I'm
on The Young Turks I'm a coho ok I know
you are your passion
[Music]
glad to be back our guests camera now is
getting all fuzzy so fix that upset
about yourself at Sally Cohen CNN
contributor I want to be clear here this
is what I was referencing where you
talked about how Sharia law can also
mean what it does in England where
Sharia councils in some place will sway
over things such as marriage and
horseradish Muslims have those councils
are ultimately and rightly subjected to
secular laws of the state however that's
untrue that is untrue that explain to me
the National councils okay seventy five
percent seventy let me explain to you
seventy-five percent of Muslim marriages
in the UK are actually not legally
recognized a woman in the UK if they get
married in a way that is not legally
recognized this is the vast majority in
the UK in Sharia Courts they have no
recourse
they can't initiate divorce their
husband merely needs to say divorce
divorce divorce this is mainstream and
that's why I wrote the piece I endorsed
the government of the UK in which by the
way is doing so with the moms and Muslim
scholars going in and reviewing the
practice of those of those Sharia Courts
it's horribly unsuccessful would you
argue that the UK is better off right
now it should be subject here's my
points Elia this is important this is
important let me go back to you said you
wanted to get into the nuance you said
you wanted to go into the nuance of
Tunisia of Malaysia said we can do that
so we did your first thing so I want to
get into that are you let me ask you let
me know no ha thing that's really
important let me let me do this do you
believe that it has been better for the
care has it been a net loss of civil
rights for many women across the UK with
the encroachment of Islam and Sharia
well let me just dig into my deep
knowledge and experience as a British
person
I don't forward record wave record rape
record spousal abuse record terrorism
Siddiqui the woman who is he
Sally it's you and I talking here's what
I'm saying Steven in the UK a muslim
scholar in muslim woman a feminist
muslim woman is heading the government
led inquiry into sharia courts to see if
they are messed up or not so you can't
blame all islam and the reason for that
would be i we need to make these courts
subject to the constitution so there you
have and the reason for that would be
why would be : sally why why now do they
feel they need to do this but you can't
blame Islam yes these Muslim leaders who
are no one yes you can and I do entirely
blame at that about progressives
traditional moving forward in a religion
versus regressive noise because they
don't want to move forward do you look
at Turkey as an example you look at
Lausanne you look at Malaysia as an
example with a record number of churches
right these are places that you I've
been there at Fox News when you and and
left his progressive held out Turkey for
a long time as a great example bastion
of secular rights in the Islamic world
Malaysia Indonesia they've all regrets
it's impossible Islam has never
progressed and it can't progress because
of the founder of the feast Muhammad and
the Sharia law regardless of the
interpretation that has been created
thereof there's let me go back to this
point this is really importance is
pivotal is there a single Islam one
Islamic country in the world where you
think that there are equal rights for
women gay people apostates one because
it's important aims to be a track record
to support you say eight nations have
elected a woman head of state and last I
checked the United States has okay well
let me counter that with this there have
been plenty of there been there been
plenty of gay and transgender people
appointed to cabinets who didn't have
what you claimed were civil rights with
marriage bathroom I didn't ask you that
though I asked you any place that has
any rights that wouldn't be considered
equal rights
not if they elected a woman the first
country that decriminalized
homosexuality in the world was actually
a Muslim country right now I'm asking if
there's any place on earth right now
where you would consider them to have
progressive equal rights the things that
you would criticize the Westboro Baptist
Church as you have a church of 12
members who are inbred but an entire
country is there one
you win hey by the way they're also
treating gay people pretty badly in
Uganda and that's because of comparing
tribal no no this is important it's
conflating an issues comparing tribalism
to modern advanced countries that have
systematically decided to deny rights in
a very violent theologically based way
is not fair oh I see so the only way to
reconcile Uganda as a discriminatory
nation is to just call them backwards
and tribal but yes are you actually yes
it has nothing to do with Christianity
it has nothing to do with Christian it
has to do with being a third world
country yes Egypt the third world
countries UAE is is is Qatar
well it's not fair let's take let's take
compared to modern modern countries as
here in the United States and Republican
leaders here in the United States tied
to conservative Christian interests
helped push for the criminalization of
homosexuality in Uganda so that there
was American Christian influence in that
and look if we want to go back how long
we have to go back in the United States
to look at when Christianity still by
the way don't you have answer my
question no but if you're if you're
barred here one simple statement one
simple no but you need to answer the
question first you say one country is
there one can we just say no and then
continue okay I'm also saying that if
the bar if your bar and I love that bar
alright Human Rights gay that's an
example I completely support that as a
bar for you know modern progression of
Rights and justice around the world
last I checked first of all I can't help
but be struck and I love you I love
you're not gay shirt I know you are
supporter of gay rights but you have to
know that your side of the aisle has not
historically been the ones going woohoo
let's get gay rights I think comparing
yeah I think comparing a penis cake to
throwing them off of rooftops is silly
you know what you're right it's not the
same thing but it's not like you get to
wave the big gay flag and be like hey
we're so progressive and treated and I'm
doing it more than the lesbian liberal
you're gonna quit you're gonna keep
waving your flag right
about about the Pew polling on what I
did 30% of Trump supporters in Carolina
don't touch me which one scores again it
matters goodies along matters we have to
go to a break so let me wrap this up a
little web extension you know kill
people for being gay in this country to
the issue is progress it's not one
religion or another they all can do
better that's I don't except one hasn't
and it's hundreds of millions of people
who refuse to and I wish that you would
support your Brett be consistently
support the progressive rights no no not
not even a majority not even a majority
of Muslims would be as tolerant to you
in the way you're complaining about
Christian conservatives it would be far
less tolerant not even a majority of the
1.6 billion Muslims okay Sally cone will
go to web extender for people listening
at Sally cone on Twitter go delighted
with credit come where she's uncensored
because she has a filthy dirty mouth
you'll serous you will hear it and be
appalled stay tuned
[Music]
on now for the adventures of the white
privilege boy
[Music]
now hey there boys good to see ya and
what can I do you for
thanks mr. MacArthur well you can start
by giving us everything in the cash
register
well golly is that a firearm you're
pointing at me there yeah I'm very
disappointed in you boys you don't care
empty it out oh I suppose boys will be
boys I'm going to have to call the
sheriff you know but you've got me for
now go ahead take everything all right
now that's one for you that's one for
you go ahead Texan Bazooka Joe and get
out of here you Rascals all those boys
what pickle will they find themselves in
next stay tuned for next week's
installment of adventures of the white
privilege boys
[Music]
[Music]
glad to be back second hour that was
Sally Kohn oh by the way unveiling a new
shirt hoho let me show people watching
what is this there you go you got red
red Sonia is not gage yard there are you
off you smuggling some raisins over
there
I look like Jennifer Aniston and Friends
with the rubber nipples yeah like every
episode yeah I think those were fake
rubber nipples I think we did we had it
because Courtney Cox had an all time -
really yeah
quite often disgusting horrible you know
what I found Phoebe the most attractive
because she was funny yeah she was
funnier she was way funnier I know I
Courtney Cox I like the character I
didn't find her funny Jennifer okay I
know it drove me up a wall honey Cox
yeah
anyway this is going to be in the not
merchandise store when we go hashtag
never daily so stop asking but what do
we have a potential what four or five
t-shirts now and yes this you know which
is a figment of your imagination it's ma
doesn't exist so Sally Kohn III dig
Sally comb I like her she can be funny
some people were saying that Steven you
kept saying this is important I did I
repeated myself with that because it was
important I do appreciate the drinking
games that people play you I appreciate
about Sally she seems like unlike some
of my even hashtag SJW friends she seems
like she could maintain a relationship
it's separate from her politics Sally
just hardly is very defined on the other
side of the aisle it's true and you know
what she's a genuinely kind person she
genuinely caring person and that counts
for something I have people on the right
who we know people who've been on the
show people who are big-name guests who
are who are pricks so we have Kristen
Bell released this video was at HuffPo
we covered it in the website I just I
just think it's important this is I just
see where this is it is just it is
leftist feminism crystallized for you
and it's been making the rounds and it's
hilarious its history women can be
hilarious you so let's roll a couple of
these clips that's of course send it
around the pay gap roll clip
is your company looking to maximize
their output while cutting back on costs
why outsource all your production to
faraway countries like India China and
Narnia when we have the cheapest and
best workforce right here in the good ol
US of A women do you notice something
there don't say it
the very beginning of her video is the
only argument that's needed against the
premise of the video she doesn't we talk
about that all the time right that's the
first thing I thought when I watch it
like does she not even know if you
believe the myth
do you not realize if a corporation
could save could only spend 70 cents on
every dollar in labor costs they would
never hire a man again and here's
something from the left so it completely
debunked the entire premise of your
video and here's what's so funny about
about the left the corporations are evil
corporations trample on the little man
they outsource jobs they'll do anything
they'll do anything they'll destroy
anybody they'll they'll end any lives
they'll destroy any households just to
increase their profits by a single
percentage point except for when it
comes to hiring women they forgo 23%
profit because they hate vaginas
is it me am I the only one seeing this
no are we supposed to believe that
greedy goldman sachs greedy corporate
fat cats they're so hateful they're
complete and total sociopaths all
successful wealthy business owners
who've been vilified as the 1% but they
checked that at the door because their
priority their greed is superseded by
their hatred of women that they're
willing to forego 23% 23% of labor cost
more if you just hire it yeah the black
ones an Indian we'll just hire the black
ones in the Indian ones yeah we have
more Clips roles that's right with pink
sourcing women are a bargain at the
workplace since you only have to pay
them 77 cents on the dollar
well the next clue also you don't have
to pay for women's birth control and if
they do get knocked up when they leave
to have the baby you get off scot-free
but don't worry guys your boner pills
are still covered also notice this is an
entirely female cast I'm assuming
writing and it's offensively unfunny
nothing like perpetuating the original
stereotype broads I think that mrs.
Sonia the terminators harbour control
isn't covered your birth control is
covered but your boner pills it's it's
one of the well it's it's entirely again
refuted by her very next point let's
roll that clip best of all you can
promote literally anyone else besides
them especially if they're less
qualified you're at 3 o clock cuddle
this is the female writing for comedy I
mean they could have hired somebody
funny to do it we have a clip about the
what's the next one is it the Tampax or
the maternity leave we'll see okay
after all women don't even really want
to be working anyway they'd rather be
home taking care of the family yes yes
that's true
exactly everything they said it requires
a borderline [ __ ] person to make
these statements with zero
self-awareness you can save money by
hiring women for 70 cents on the dollar
oh that flies in the face of all
economics women gotta be at home right
sarcasm of course must be home women
have wombs
and they make babies and so they're
biologically driven to yes yes next clip
that's all of you add that's all the
ways in a crap what would it talk about
maternity leave they talk about their
old maternity leave if men if men or
women were there that you can bet the
paternity leave would be paid no by the
way maternity leave is already a thing
okay
it already exists plenty of plenty of
companies do it more importantly that's
not a quality no men are out there
demanding a year off with pay
unless you're a cop who's screwed up
you're not getting paid when you're on
leave that's not a quality you want
special favors she goes on and talk
about a Tampax no and then but it's all
made up for by free tampons in the
bathroom huh you just bitched about how
there's not free birth control
it is perfect this is this is this is
what's so wrong with this Kristen Bell
is is she she is considering she is
putting herself for as an ambassador of
women with this video this video
portrays women as stupid unfunny and
incapable of understanding basic
economics it is the worst
I just think about that because you know
the only argument if people are ingredie
the score per --it overlords aren't
greedy then they're just hiring men
because maybe they're possibly more
skilled at the job but they can't they
can't actually go with our argument
thought about that that's a good point I
said but that's one they can't roll with
because that that would entirely
diminish their argument that women are
just as capable as men it's like no no
we're into the no where is that even
factored into the equation that yeah men
might be better for that job that's it
that's I mean it's that's it unless they
go to the argument that maybe just the
white man is holding them down from the
proper training or education now that's
all if that's what that's what they go
yeah there are more women in college now
there are more grants and scholarships
for breasts there's more research that
goes into breast cancer nobody cares
about wieners everyone wants to save
boobs women want to save their boobs and
we want you to save your boobs it's a
lot easier to get people on board with
women with female causes there as a
matter of fact I would love to do it
either with Lauren southern maybe Tommy
Lauren and just put out you want to know
where women enjoy privilege more than
any social media same exact tweet from a
mail account female she will get 50
times interaction speed a female causes
that's the stuff that gives children
nightmares like those clowns he keeps
showing me a picture of Lena Dunham Lena
Dunham where she put it she's obsessed
with showing her body this one and it's
always front page salon HuffPo
it's like liberals are like hey Lena
Dunham Lena Dunham hey can you show us
your tits we're kind of low on traffic
it's all the time I think we can say
that on air we're talking us brother
they were like isn't it great we have a
podcast going up tonight
where Lena Dunham has not done anything
this week to comment on isn't great and
then she interjected herself this
morning with that with it's just like
Hillary Clinton's have just put her up
there propping this girl up I mean but I
mean the proper up it has to be like you
know it has to be like Dirk sees coming
on the temple with everyone Carrie I
mean you know Lena Dunham not supposed
to be honest that requires the people to
do their deadlifts it is they constantly
try and push these rings as strong women
and they're not they're the weakest
among us Kristen Bell is a stupid person
she doesn't understand economics she
doesn't understand what the pay gap and
here's a deal if you want to talk to
young girls and you want to inspire them
why not put forward like a Christine
hoff sommers like a Carly Fiorina why
not put somebody who understands the
economy who understands running a
business who actually employs people
someone who wasn't just born with great
looks and mediocre acting ability and
that's how they made their their bones
Carly Fiorina had to work for it
someone like um I don't know I'm sure
there's some female scientists I'm
pretty quick that's one of my bet I'm
pretty a time able to think of things in
my feet I couldn't think of a woman who
who they're all dead like Rosa Parks is
who I'd toss forward but you can't trot
her out to inspire little girls I don't
know but you my point remains but Jude
made a good point there it doesn't allow
for this the mere fact that sometimes
men are better at the job right again
this goes back to the ISM the ISM the
pie chart think about the pie chart that
we showed earlier the ISM of the world
through the prism through which you see
it if it's just about there's this out
there and I'm only getting this much a
it's not sure you're not getting 70
cents in the dollar but again if I found
out that I was making 70 cents in the
dollar for a female job I would go okay
well why what is it that they're adding
that I'm not sometimes there's injustice
not always but the ISM is that's I need
my piece of the pie
because vagina and that's how they see
the world this is what yeah you do have
to create your filter you do have to
have your moral compass I know a lot of
you
the libertarian atheist don't believe in
isms well you know what it changes
things we have Andrew Clavin no Hilary
cutting up next week Oh headline next
disconnect yeah crazy
[Music]
and we're back it's time again to play
America's favorite game show spot the
real firearm now the rules are simple
one of these firearms is reap the other
is an accurate BB gun replica yeah it
looks like he's dead what's a real one
loaded hey Jared
what are you doing shooting bad guys
with what
where'd you get it yeah 50 knock on a
month's need it more clearly so our
audience can hear they are 15.com that's
better
they sell guns now yeah they do are they
any good in to the best we're from here
15 accom kaput
come on you really make that sound
denied the budget for sound effects with
150 from Willie Regina calm hey how do
you know they're bad guys Debra's in
burkas that's racist
[Music]
Miguel was doing a jig there just a
little great great to be back glad to be
back we have great guests we have Andrew
Clavin coming up next but before that
right now I think do we is secretary
Hillary Clinton on the line you got her
Secretary Hillary Clinton are you there
Secretary Clinton are you with us oh
yeah thanks for having me Steven really
glad to be here well thanks for coming
how're you feeling today oh I feel I
feel great really ready to break through
that glass ceiling Steven look good
because you had a pretty serious health
scare this week that let a lot of people
to start questioning you know current a
right-wing conspiracy from the the bag
of deplorable
I could tell you it's going to take a
lot more than simple allergies to keep
Hillary Rodham Clinton down I thought it
was pneumonia this week I thought it was
pneumonia that you had it was it was
pneumonia
it was totally pneumonia so you just
miss well you know as well as I do
Steven that allergies typically leads to
pneumonia no I don't know that I don't
think anyway now did you see Parkinson's
that sounded like you said Parkinson's
forgive me what's your latest policy
proposal an immediate increase in
federal funding to find a cure for
epilepsy and or Parkinson's see now that
just sounds suspect well maybe to a
sexist and what are is that what you are
Steven are you a sexist you just look
different as all I'm saying
Wow so Steven well for starters the duct
tape and stick moving your mouth oh this
oh you know this is the new look I'm
bringing Steven if you read People
magazine you know I'm very
fashion-forward for example I brought
back pants suits no I was the first to
wear that kungfu jacket and I would
argue
I wore it better and this is the new
duct tape and tree twig look Steven I'm
pretty excited about it's gonna catch on
I'm not so sure about that
Steven to catch on it seems like more of
a necessity than a fashion
okay all right Hillary where's the best
place for people to support you yes
thanks Steven people can support me at
Hillary Clinton dot org mm-hmm
Donald Trump is literally Hitler dot AG
of porno and epilepsy
now calm one's a big one Steve yeah I
can imagine it is secretary Hillary
Clinton everybody thank clearly um it's
big yet I wish we would have had more
she has a look oh jeez I've seen her
look better yeah let's see myself look
better tan is not my color
cream whatever you call him good thing
we'll have another colored shirt well
you know you sound off on what you think
tweet me at s Crowder do you think she
has the pneumonia or do you think maybe
a little bit a little bit something
wrong with that head actually just a
touch of eight now here's the thing that
you know I you know what people gonna
say well why is it okay for you to mock
something that could be Parkinson's and
not Donald Trump because I'm not running
for president that's it I say her
horrible stuff horrendous stuff and
people can criticize me for it hey
speaking of being critical this is a big
story this week I didn't see a lot of
people talking about this Jared doesn't
pay attention to the website did you
hear about the Syrian refugees I heard
vaguely things facts the united by has
accepted thus far andrew Clavin next by
the way ten thousand eight hundred and
one Syrian refugees guess how many of
those are Christian oh I did hear about
this yeah it's not a not a good no 56 56
that's half of one percent ten percent
of all Syrians are Christian means
there's 2.2 million Christians in Syria
and we've only accepted so again if
you're going to talk about actual
numbers about
fortunately to the population 10% of
refugees are Christian less than 0.5
have been invited in this PR stunt to
the United States what does that tell
you let me ask you something not only
are 10% of Syrian refugees Christian but
considering what's going on with with
Isis considering what's going on in
Syria wouldn't it stand to reason that
more of the actual refugees considering
that Christians are being burned alive
and slaughtered and targeted first
solely for being Christian your honor
would it stand to reason that more of
the refugees fleeing should be Christian
is that outside the realm of reason am I
am i off-base no the logic checks out
Stephen yeah yeah when you talk of
course of course Muslims kill other
Muslims in these countries but you get
you get priority access if you're a
Christian there if you're not facing
Mecca five times a day you're being put
in the fast lane that's the Express
Checkout twelve items or less because
you you've got a crucifix for some
reason we're taking in refugees at a
record number people who are who are
committing rape at record numbers in
Germany they just found 1,500 child
brides in refugee settlements but in the
United States
statistically none of them are
Christians if you actually do the math
and do it right here
yeah carry the four mm-hmm add the 2%
yeah bull I can't say the full court you
can't do the full world world world
words in the radio world Hillary I
someone stabbed me with a pen not not at
a other pen pen just stabbed my eyes
with a pen because I don't wanna have to
look at Jared's surprised Lena Dunham
pictures this is huge this should tell
you that again Democrats as they go out
that they don't really care about the
poor Joe Biden doesn't give me a Hillary
Clinton they're not charitable people
there's a great book by Brooks who
really cares and it wasn't it wasn't a
conservator who set out listen
conservatives give more particularly
Christian conservatives they're more
charitable they put their money where
their mouth is left us don't same thing
with the Rep they don't really want to
help people it's a PR stunt they want to
go out and talk about how progressive
they are and know
Falls and look at all the refugees we're
bringing in well listen I don't I don't
understand the net game here for them
except pandering to Muslims except
pandering to potential terrorists
I understand my leftist wouldn't want to
put their best foot forward and say
let's just bring in more Christians they
are the ones getting slaughtered they
are the ones being targeted first and
we're bringing in the people who follow
the religion and the prophet who are
doing the slaughtering it's a matter of
fact if anything I bet you more
Americans would be comfortable with
Syrian refugees if we could vet them as
Christians because we know they're
actually fleeing people killing them
doesn't mean that all Muslims are coming
to Christians but it's more of a
guarantee that the Christians in Syria
are likely not the ones doing the
slaughtering it's not a gear it's not
it's not for sure it just puts it on
that side of the ledger oh my god all
right Andrew Klavan coming up next I
don't know he's half Jewish just stay
[Music]
[Music]
right so this next guest is a
provocateur right where it's like oh of
course I said raises Chapelle what I but
I didn't say racist right that's what
she does so again Facebook I wasn't
trending keeping up with this guy's
discussion the recognizes me I'll give
them my phone number we can talk about
it over drinks again my name is not
Tommy I'm more in southern and I'm not
direct messaging you think about it okay
whatever this is this is done between
sound fun can I come
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
of course that is Pogo one of our
favorite artists has provided us with
all kinds of great music and/or Lotter
with clap louder with Crowder ah gosh
what am i I don't know what's happening
someone stabbed me with a pen my mouth
isn't working today I'm ashamed of
myself but I'm glad to have our next
guest
he's been on a show quite a bit you know
him you love him his a new book out and
we'll talk about it as well called the
great good thing a secular Jew comes to
faith in Christ oh jeez no that's going
to cause some triggering you can follow
him on Twitter at Andrew Clavin send you
out of Clavin thank you dude it's good
to see you I thought you were holding a
pipe there that's your glasses it's just
my glasses yes well you'll probably want
to if not gay Jared brings up another
image of Lena Dunham oh dear Lord unpack
yet handle it again my Twitter feed is
gone I didn't see the image of Lena
Dunham I thankfully that's why I'm not
blind but yes all I've been hearing
about it sounds like it was horrific
well first we want to talk about Hillary
Clinton because I know that you know a
lot about her and I know that you've had
Parkinson's and/or epilepsy in the past
but your book yes yes so your your book
is out here and we've talked about this
a lot of people obviously still send you
the anti-semitic remarks but not a lot
of Jews lose one to the other team so
this is this is pretty big and you could
make some enemies why don't I gaze that
way yeah well you know it's not only
going from being Jewish to being
Christian it's going from being a
secular Jew who didn't believe in
anything and was raised in an atmosphere
of disbelief and worked I mean I've
spent all my life working in Hollywood
and in New York publishing where a
mention of Jesus would die of loneliness
you know where it just it just was not
the thought didn't exist and so the
reason I want I thought my story was
kind of interesting was I think a lot of
us just about all of us are living in
that culture we're living in a culture
that basically believes that people are
meat puppets that have no souls we talk
about having an adrenaline rush as if we
were some kind of chemistry
set and I just thought you know I
thought this through for 35 years and
I'm pretty sure I'm right about this and
I came to the conclusion that that image
of human beings doesn't make any sense
we're in the whereas the Christian image
of people does make sense and that's why
I wrote it I thought if you follow my
journey maybe you'll see a way out of
where you're stuck
well that provides a little more context
as opposed to a practicing Jew becoming
you know becoming a Christian um but you
know that's the same story for anyone
who's actually a Christian everyone has
to make the decision at some point
that's one thing like where you born
Christian well no you're not your
parents might be Christian but by
definition you can't be born a Christian
it's a decision you have to make but
this is proof positive of what I've
talked about a lot Andrew I have a lot
of 80s too who listened to the show a
lot of atheists who come on the show and
this idea that you're in an atheist club
and you get intellectual points right
away the second you come out of the
closet and everyone else has gotten it
wrong listen there are people who could
probably eat your lunch and in a
theological debate and me too obviously
however I think you'd be hard-pressed to
find anyone who says yeah Andrew Klavan
is a dummy you're a smart guy who still
believes but generationally younger was
gay right write someone off if you're
not no longer one of the New Atheists
well yeah and that's the way I felt when
I was half educated it was as I became
more educated that actually that stuff
started to collapse that's what it is
it's it depends on you to accept certain
assumptions of a semi educated elite the
journalists the guys who write the
op-eds the guys who make fun of you on
on TV you know the actors and all this
stuff right fun of religious people on
TV
it just is basically saying to you this
is the cool crowd we're the smart guys
right a problem is not that cool and
they're definitely not that smart
well some of them are very smart but a
lot of them aren't and it is this sort
of blanket I'm an atheist in people go
well he must be a critical thinker right
away right because many of these kids
are raised in youth group or whatever
and they they're going against the grain
I've noticed that a lot of even talk
with Sargon about that I know you give a
lot of other atheists a pass simply
because they claim to be an atheist and
you see them using straw man all the
time you see them being intellectually
disingenuous but because they claim a
theist mantel you give them the okay and
once you start to read their books and
you really start to pick apart their
arguments even the smartest of them do
not have good arguments their arguments
simply
don't hold together and I followed them
virtually all of them I've read almost
all of them at this point and their
arguments don't hold together even
Christopher Hitchens a brilliant
brilliant writer whenever he would talk
about his atheism suddenly began to
spout nonsense and it just it just was
stuff that didn't make sense oh you know
Christians are some Christians are mean
so there's no God you think like really
that's the level then but I understand
what you're what you're saying and it's
certainly his debate with Dinesh D'Souza
were great very entertaining to watch
and very very much the polar opposite of
Dinesh's debate with chanc Weger of the
young turks yeah I'm talking about him
used to be friends I'm like this is a
new breed man people are no longer
respectful in here ideas they just crap
on you which you'll probably get for
that so were commuter find the book
unless they've lost the debate that's
why yes exactly
where's the people get it on Amazon yep
get it on Amazon you can pre-order it
now and it's out next week what I'm
sorry I I would love to but I how about
how about how about not Thursday yes now
no Dean hang up Dean hang up again I
told him he's a good guy Andrew he just
why just I don't I love him but why is
that the problem Thursday's I don't know
why it does I'm sorry Andrew hey uh well
uh task force want to clarify now that
we're at the point in the primaries you
you were not on board with trumpet I
don't think you were ever hashtag never
Trump are you drum you so you okay so
are you gonna vote for Donald Trump now
between him and Hillary's boy it sure is
looking that way I mean my problem my
problem with the never Trump errs is not
what they say about Donald Trump I don't
like the guy very much I have a lot of
big big problems with him sure my
problem is as they say like PJ O'Rourke
said it best he said you know Hillary
Clinton is bad but she's bad within
normal parameters and I don't agree with
that I think if that's normal parameters
normal has moved way way too I mean I
think I think Hillary Clinton is really
really bad I think she's corrupt I think
she's you know dishonest
almost bye-bye roach he's almost lies
without thinking about it like a convict
or something you know right and I think
her history is a history of abuse and
greed as Colin Powell said the other day
you agree and nastiness and I just think
that you know with Donald Trump I think
there is a vanishingly small chance that
he will do a good job or a good job with
something right Hillary Clinton I just
don't see it well it's it's funny that
you mentioned that about Donald Trump
and Hillary Clinton doesn't even stand
to gain sometimes I'm certain you know
what well talk about that Anthony
Kamiya's made that point why would you
lie about why would you just say you
have pneumonia yeah why why lie about
this like that's this that's why it's a
story because you there's nothing to
gain by said hey hey this Hill is
Hillary Clinton sick nah she's all right
[Laughter]
yes she's a little tired before they
send her off to live on a farm and you
never see her again
did you okay I know the conspiracies are
going by you've got to be that looks
like more than pneumonia doesn't it
well that one thing could be pneumonia
and I have no luck I have no proof of
anything the other thing is if you were
a doctor if you were a doctor what you
would be saying because gee I don't know
I didn't examine her right that was
that's what every duck but but gee it's
been going on so long she's been
coughing and coughing for months this is
not just something that happened right
away you know I mean you know one thing
I think that it could be that I don't
hear people mention this could be
emphysema you know like she could have a
slow lung disease that's gonna kill her
eventually that is making it a weak and
making her prone to things like them oh
well um that was she smoked you know
what it may be it may just be that when
you sell your soul your body collapses
inward on the emptiness yes yes you
smoker I think it's just the fire say
that you stole my thunder ah I feel good
about him no because I mean though I was
tracking with Andrew Cleveland on a joke
yes I think you spend that I was gonna
say gates of hell more descriptive and
he's the writer here no I
it is one of those entitlement ill this
week and I'm going oh right this is real
this is something you know that you can
verify this is clearly happening and
they lied about it so it would have been
catnip for four clicks for web traffic
we know that just peddling and
conspiracies but this is something
genuine and the fact that they lied
about it it could just be that's force
of habit
but it seems seems a little more
sinister and buried in those : pal
emails that got hacked buried and there
was a reference to her being unable to
climb a few steps to reach a stage do
you remember that you happened to notice
that he talked about somebody saying
that she has been really and this was a
long time it was like over a year ago
talked about her being unable to reach
the steps something's wrong with her
it's just a lot of stuff going on it's
kind of like you know where they say
where there's smoke there's fire that's
not always true but there's an awful lot
of smoke I mean I would just attribute
the step thing that she waddles around
like kim jeong-hoon and a little kung fu
jr. I can't imagine she's very mobile
it's kind of like when you have an older
and older people gonna say well yeah
like an older dog who has a bad hips and
you kind of gotta get them moving in the
morning it's not any one thing I mean
I've been coughing up green stuff for a
year so that's I mean I could take now
you're taking the one things but just
it's the accumulation of all that does
make a little let her guessing she's
gonna say not good go ahead I'm worried
the thing is becoming like psycho where
she's actually like just stuffed in this
in the attic you know it's if that's the
case I mean at least obviously bill
hasn't been doing it someone's stuff in
her so she's got something going for
this point come on
that's worse than Lena Dunham you know
when Powell said that bill was still
sleeping with bimbos at least he's
healthy enough to view yes yes exactly
well don't you know your boner pills are
covered apparently according to Kristen
Bell as opposed to birth control here's
something you just touched on the Colin
Powell emails everyone talked about it
and the whole story was he coached her
on how to hide things in a private email
server know what you just talked about
is very important where he said that she
couldn't get and everything she touched
she ruined I think due to hubris
something like that everything she he'd
mentioned hubris but
basically saying she is immensely
unsuccessful she's grating he doesn't
like her he talked about her health he
talked about telling her not to do
specifically what she did with her email
server and specifically not to lie about
it he did some things that were you know
less than savory but it's like everyone
just glossed over the stuff that is
damning on Hillary oh the networks are
hardly covered it they went to write to
the Trump stuff he called Trump an idiot
and all this stuff you know the thing
that's so irritating about the Clintons
in general is that we our memory is so
short that we forget that they've been
doing this for decades now you know like
when Hillary was senator she was taking
money from Corning Glass to get them
deals with the Chinese which she took
that money from the Russian plutonium
company and as Secretary of State
allowed them to buy 20% of our uranium
supply and in Canada I mean she has been
taking money for political favors for a
long time and you know I hate to bring
it up but those are our favors you know
she was a servant of us people and she
was selling them for private cash and
I'm like yeah it's it's kind of it was
some would say a disqualifier at some
point but like you said when you change
the parameters of normal I mean you're
talking about the Clintons house of
cards has basically been created around
them and people just forget about that
it's like they are the villains that
create one of most successful shows in
modern history it is it is so it's you
know you're you're probably going to
surprise a lot of people by saying
you're you're likely going to vote for
Trump you know a lot of people are going
to say that Jew is never gonna vote
Trump you'll get that well you know I've
made no secret of my feelings about the
guy I think he is a bad dude I basically
lost this election already I mean
there's nobody who's gonna get elected
who's gonna cut back the government
nobody's gonna get elected is gonna make
me more free let the country lessen debt
more safe none of that's going to happen
it's just not happening so the question
is how do we get through the next four
years with as little damage as possible
and I think there is you know some
people disagree with this I think there
is a chance that Trump will make a good
Supreme Court appointment that would be
major how it would be a big deal and I
think that increasing the security on
the border is important I think you know
I I think he there's some good things
that I think he could
I think there are a lot of good things
that he can do and I would think it's
likely that he you know appoint someone
better to the Supreme Court um not only
possibly I would say likely if only
because he's beholden to some level of
honesty even though I don't necessarily
know how this we can talk I don't think
he's particularly dishonest I think he's
thoughtless sometimes it's just words
come out and he has to walk him back I
don't picture him as sinister or
premeditated as Hillary Clinton Andrew
Klavan at Andrew Klavan and we'll talk
with him more after this break it's a
break I forgot what a break
[Music]
you
[Music]
though the Hillary broke your head from
side to side can we collapse you with me
do the Hillary shake your head like
you've got Parkinson's nothing to see
here just plain theology Hillary Hillary
though the Hillary
throw your head from side to side can we
collapse you with me do the Hillary the
Hillary
[Music]
we're back at Andrew Klavan he is there
pardon us for that horrible break and
dancing Andrew that was bad yes yes well
wills and this is it's um it's a big
part of the program this is indicative
of the quality that people come to know
and love yes I do recommend people go
out the new book one more plug for it
the great good thing a secular Jew comes
to faith in Christ because it's actually
one of the few books you're more of a
you know you're more of a fiction writer
that conservatives are sort of I guess
to guess even just social conservatives
wouldn't want to read it's my first
non-fiction book and yeah it was really
it was really difficult to switch and
tell your own person you know your own
personal story but I'm really happy with
the way it came out and everyone who's
ready so far has been incredibly nice
about it so I think people like it oh
gosh he's doing the Trump
listen everyone else loves it everyone
loves it for Hillary Clinton's book
already truthfully okay honestly here's
the thing I will say this I get a little
bit of a when you know that the polls
tie and I see Hillary Clinton you know
III see her doing poorly even though
I've been critical of Trump and I think
people should what we've tried to do is
honestly be critical of Trump when fair
and support him when right but I'd be
lying if I said I don't get a little a
tingle down my leg when Hillary is doing
poorly I'm with you too and it you the
best thing about a Trump election is the
people whose heads will explode and I
actually want to be there like in the
New York Times editorial offices when
people just go like you know and just
watch like scanners remember scanners
where the guy's head just blow up I
think just watching that would be worth
the entire price
try to remember scanners did you ever
see scanners not gauge Eric no awesome
and heads explode it will be much like
that yes I think was specially in Los
Angeles bill burrs talked about that we
have some questions from the Twitter
Andrew for you someone set out what
about Andrews thoughts on Gary the
libertarian I love all you have to say
Gary the libertarian because well I mean
first of all I think the guy the guy's
not gonna win so he doesn't matter as a
realistic possibility but you know every
time I don't know what it is with
libertarians I consider myself basically
a libertarian I don't care what anybody
else does in there
personal lives or anything all these
guys can talk about is pot you know you
talked about he doesn't know where
Aleppo is you know it's like a leper
do they make pot there you know it's a
but the minute you hit the subject of
dope he'll go for 20 minutes and he
doesn't stop and you go like okay I get
it dope should be legal fine I'm fine
with that but stop sign just where's the
resolve boats oh yeah I love what my
favorite part about that we ran this
last week where is Aleppo I go are you
are you serious a lot though it's one of
the most pivotal cities in Syria he goes
got it got it
like the God it was clear like stop it
stop letting this go any further down
the embarrassment trail what's it what's
up oh but but if you ask him what Aleppo
red is it's a stream and yeah it is it
is very bizarre that they make it their
single pivotal issue we've talked about
that for me even with liberty but what's
funny but alot of these libertarians who
are pot heads now all of a sudden have
abandon it for Trump because it's this
trend and they don't care at all that
he's going to be probably the worst
president on pot if you look at what he
tied you know they love the hackers and
Donald Trump was going to jail Snowden
I'm not saying he's necessarily wrong
I'm saying the people who would have
been libertarian have abandoned it for a
trend but the pot thing you in my
position is listen if you wanna smoke
pot fine states should have the right to
vote and let people smoke pot I think a
lot of states probably will but just
don't lie and say that it's medicine or
Big Pharma's behind is colluding to get
oh they had their seven patents right
now on marijuana drug there's only one
that works for chemo patients for
appetite they don't want it as medicine
they want to get high my thing is just
say hey probably the jury's still out
there probably is a lot of benefit could
be bad for some people but it's my right
I want to get high they said that and
states legalize it I have no problem
with it
even that is upsetting to libertarians
but it's fine but did he miss the new
story where the Islamists are trying to
wipe us off the face of the earth I mean
that he missed the news story like where
are we're 400 trillion dollars in debt
you know it's like great it legalized
pot leave me alone but that's not the
only issue it's up in this election it's
like
he's never read anything else except
like you know the latest you know where
you where you can score good stuff yeah
well I think he was probably taking bong
hits while they were talking about
Aleppo Syria and Gary turns what don't
you notice isn't it funny how all the
libertarians who run for office you know
this is the thing this is my life's work
but I've never smoked pot oh no I don't
think he's a serious candidate I think a
lot of liberty austin peterson we
actually had on the show quite a bit
probably wasn't a super serious
candidate but was actually able to
formulate a thought was certainly more
consistent my problem was open borders
with him he was an open borders guy and
he was making the case which i
understand he was making the cases a lot
of libertarian economists made however
that wasn't a time where it wasn't
entirely a welfare state right people
coming here for jobs is very different
from people flocking here for free stuff
that's right
that's right and they used to go back I
mean it used to be they would come in
seasonally and go back and that was kind
of a system and it worked fine but now
they come in and they stay and and you
know what it doesn't make any sense
anyway you can't have a country without
borders how would you even find it on a
map you know that's what a country is a
country is a place surrounded with lines
you know it's a piece of ground
surrounded with lines that other people
can't come into that is what it said for
a lot of Canada it's mostly just honor
system yeah it was it really is when I
used to go through the border all the
time oh my gosh it was so embarrassing
we would go through SWAT we're all
American my mama's french-canadian she
immigrated to the United States we'd go
through the border and Champlain go to
Plattsburgh New York Plattsburgh this
podunk town with nothing there but we
were in Canada so they had Taco Bell so
we would go for the weekend and the joke
they would always say is I remember just
being like ok here's a security
checkpoint and then nothing but empty
land with zero protection and my dad
would say yeah here are three citizens
and one alien and a mom would go she's
french-canadian as I can anyway sorry
this conversation took a weird turn but
was a perfect opportunity for that story
Andrew Clavin your book title we have to
go what is it great
good thing the great good thing a
secular Jew comes to faith in Christ we
have 30 seconds right now okay Jerry
what's your stance on bagels real quick
before we go you still love them well
them they're good for Jews are good for
the Christian would be good for every I
think it's just overrated bread in a
circular shape it's cooking on a bread
all right Andrew Klavan we love them you
got them and that we'll have him back
soon at Andrew Klavan stay tuned because
we have Bob Ross right Bob Ross Ross
coming up on Hillary Clinton
[Music]
and now for The Adventures of the white
privilige boy
[Music]
did you see a look at mr. MacArthur oh
darn it there's officer Gingka what do
we do I know
let's run into that alleyway now boys
have you three been up to no good I
don't know what you're talking about
officer Jenkins well I've been getting
some phone calls
does mr. MacArthur ring a bell alright
guys run I got this i still have my BB
gun Oh Timmy I'm disappointed you know
you're not supposed to aim a loaded
firearm at an office yeah what are you
gonna do about it officer Jenkins I tell
you what I'm going to do to you Timmy
first you're going to put the loaded
firearm down I'm going to have to call
your mother first
we'll go grab an ice cream cone and talk
about it what do you say okay can I ride
in the front of the paddy wagon Oh Jimmy
usually that's not allowed but since
you're white all those boys what tickle
will they find themselves in next stay
tuned for next week's installment of
Adventures of the white privilege boys
[Music]
[Music]
all right I'm glad to be back we're in
the third hour we're going to have
Anthony Kamiya cool me yeah Anthony
coming up next after the after well we
have a cup no I'm sorry we don't have
him next right do we yeah oh that's
right gosh we're almost through the
shit's going car so you know right now
if people love that we had not long ago
Bob Ross taught us how to draw Muhammad
and lucky enough to get him back we're
lucky enough to get him back we were
very fortunate we have Bob Ross here
this evening teaching you how to draw
Hillary Clinton enjoy
[Music]
welcome back to the joy of painting I'm
Bob Roz the beauty of painting is you
can paint whatever you like we can paint
a landscape or a poor critter even this
week let's go with something topical
something in the news Secretary Hillary
Rodham Clinton has been in and there's a
lot let's do that or that you're going
to need your paintbrush some colors you
can use whatever you like
I suggest liquid whites mucus cream some
slate colors and lots of more liquid
whites lots of liquid whites in the
Hillary Clinton campaign let's get
started and draw the secretary here
let's paint the secretary herself little
blonde there for her hair not too blonde
not too blonde because it's not real
blonde you can add whatever you want
let's continue drawing the face narrow
shoulders narrow shoulders and wide
birthing hips beautiful wide birthing
hips with narrow shoulders perfect for
carrying little Chelsea perfect for
carrying little little Clinton's there
see how it's coming together very nicely
oh that's a beautiful Hillary Clinton
now she's had some health scares
recently the secretary let's draw a
little bit of she's coughing here let's
draw her coughing up some mucus that's
the mucus green I told you let's have
some green there Oh beautiful color it's
unfortunate sometimes it's associated
with sickness it's a beautiful color and
it's alright and then she's been
coughing pretty badly let's try a little
love little love that Hillary Clinton
the secretary expelled in her calls
right there you see how that's coming
together she looks a little lonely let's
give her some trees little happy trees
their little happy trees they don't have
to be complex
little happy trees but you know what she
needs more than trees this is topical we
can do something different let's give
her some bodies let's just draw some
little bodies the clinton body count
right there let's draw a little body oh
there's a vince foster look at that she
just beat the devil out of him little
bodies to keep hillary company now let's
go back to hillary herself since we're
filling this in she's had some health
scares let's draw some shake lines here
her hands and head were shaking from
some kind of disease could be
Parkinson's could be cancer epilepsy you
can pick whatever disease you like
that's the beauty of painting aids could
be whatever disease you want to draw for
Hillary Clinton could be all of them she
could have every disease Under the Sun
you know what let's draw Sun let's draw
Sun let's draw Sun up your nice warm
yellow Sun sank hello to the secretary
beating down because it was hot in New
York let's draw that hot warm Sun
beating down on Hillary making her sick
creating a sweltering bone-dry 74
degrees look at that that's coming
together nicely see no doubt as to who
that it we have to finish this up here
with her sickness she needs some help
she needs some friends let's draw her
security detail coming in right there
her security detail now you can make
them whatever color you want
they could be brown or black but let's
be honest they're most likely white
let's draw them wide most of her
security detail is going to be liquid
whites there you go it's not not her
fault people of different upbringing
some people are afraid of colored folk
they can be intimidating liquid whites
her security detail now to finish this
they're stabbing her with a diazepam pen
stopping the violent convulsions with a
diazepam pen right there let's paint
that stabbing the secretary with a
diazepam pen so she can feel all better
feeling all better look at that painting
doesn't have to be complicated look at
the beautiful picture we did and that
was a good warm-up with just her body
double when we come back we'll paint the
real thing happy painting and God bless
you my friend
[Music]
you
hmm I almost fall asleep when I listen
to was aspiring it's always inspires me
son Bob Ross he knows how to find the
silver lining and everything except for
this nothing nothing's silver or even
lines the reason you're hearing me right
now off mic is because I don't I can't
even look at my monitor not gauge erin
has made my monitor in unsafe space with
the pictures of Lena Dunham is it off
it's off okay it's off alright this off
there now I know I'm gonna you know I'll
be texting you some pictures back it's
back and then and then it's off okay
here we go
alright next time it's pictures of
clowns for you clowns not good year it
has not gay Jarrod is deathly afraid of
hide tweet him have not gay Jared the
creepiest clown pictures you can
possibly find you kept me up all night
last week what the clown pictures with
the clown picture text it's gonna happen
this week because my wife has been gone
since Monday she comes back Monday she's
a working gal and matter of fact she may
be you know what there's a lot going on
in the Crowder household right now
hashtag never daily because there's a
lot going on in the works even though
we're never going daily hashtag never
daily so stop tweeting it and asking us
she's been gone and I will tell you this
sweetheart miss you if you're if you're
watching this um it's it's it's tough
for me when my wife is gone not only
because I want to mount everything Jared
careful this is why I carry carries and
the clowns and that that's barely a joke
by the way
but I one of those things people go oh
you're trying to hook up to your wife
when I'm on air I really do try and be
sincere with people listen I think
that's one of the the good qualities of
the show is is not gay Jared and I are
genuine people
you do get a glimpse into our lives now
we keep some things private naturally
but I genuinely don't relate to people
who can't stand their wives what kind of
a [ __ ] are you to marry someone who you
think is an idiot you have to go home to
every night um
I genuinely like being with my wife I
when she's gone I miss I don't do well
and this is one thing that I think is
important because people say well why do
you you know a lot of people get mad
because you're a social conservative it
doesn't mean I'm pushing it on you it
means listen this is what's improved my
life I've always been an advocate for
marriage
I think it's a great thing I think a man
who finds a good wife find something
that is good great
even I didn't do well as a single person
you know I'll talk with people the
wife's out you're gonna you're gonna
party you're gonna know and that's not
real life that's in the movies not
everyone is Alfie okay it ends up being
the 69% wrap up burritos with some beer
and Netflix um I've never been a good
bachelor and I say this because I got a
lot of emails from from young men they
feel as though that's the norm and it's
somehow abnormal if they feel lonely
like you're a bachelor cuz so many
people who are married right if you
watch the shows they just wish they
could go back to when they were single I
am so much happier married I can't even
tell you it wasn't really something that
was that scary to me I am that way with
children so maybe send me an email or
tweet me at s Crowder with children it
still scares the daylights out of me but
I'm Way happier I was living in
Manhattan in my own apartment in the
Upper East Side was doing pretty well
financially alone if ever a bachelor
would have been thrilled it would have
been that scenario I couldn't stand it
and being married is a lot a it's more
fun because I have someone nearby who's
who's my closest friend my confidant
someone who cares about me and um also
cooks you know sex and sandwiches are a
big plus I will say this having
experienced both I don't relate to the
people to the guys who oh man I kid I
miss being single I tell you what when
you're married it's all over for me it's
been the exact opposite being married
has opened up so many opportunities it
really has been the greatest probably
the greatest blessing to my life ever I
know people say it humble the best day
and you think they have to say it
because their wife is is eavesdropping
all the best day of my life was when I
got married we have to say that and I'd
even know that the best day of my life
was when we got when I got married but
it certainly made my life a whole lot
better so she's been gone and that makes
it tough which means I'm going to be
sending you pictures of naked clowns
most likely yes on pornography some
could say it's tougher for me then yes
some good stuff or for not Gager but
don't feel abnormal guys out there don't
feel normal because you have this wife
shaped hole in your heart and you want
to fill it you've been made to feel as
though you need to sow your Wild Oats
you're not a real man if you're looking
to settle down it's not true some people
for some people you know love going to
the bar every night and popping the
pills to avoid the venereal diseases and
that's their thing and that's fine
that's their thing but it's it's not
even necessarily the norm and you don't
need to feel as though you're beta or
you somehow need to score with more
chicks or that if you're not enjoying
your single life that's the reason why
it's it's it's not the case I will tell
you in my life being married it's been a
whole lot better so I got a few emails
about that where people talk about you
know marriage and especially because
recently Hillary was in the show and um
people don't realize you know a lot of
times they don't realize that young kids
have pressure on them and it's not in
the way that they would think a lot of
young men get that pressure yeah I think
the movies and it's Hollywood just kind
of portrays all that in such a weird
light that kind of storts and perverts
how things should be
it's never the fun guy no no no ways the
guy with annoying kids and the [ __ ]
wife and they come into the house for
Christmas and it's just a nightmare and
then it wants Krampus and then at the
end they tighten like well actually it's
nice the families fulfilled and they
have some tender moment but you know
they just had to toss it in to justify
all the crap they tossed on the the
nuclear family so ah maybe it helped
somebody maybe it doesn't we'll be back
with Anthony community come here Annie
come here stay tuned
[Music]
okay so the next guy's right he's a
professional troll late you know of
course I'm gay so I gotta pass right it
says racist [ __ ]
yeah I'm not Nero
I'm Gavin McInnes I had to dye my hair
for a movie role I was playing the role
of a young man in a movie so I tried to
take off the beard the mustache 2d age
myself didn't work out great not trying
to say a mansome but I had to dye my
hair for a movie like seriously I had to
bleach this for a movie role what's your
Excuse with your mustache Jesus Christ
you don't think we can see all that fuzz
you look like Wilford Brimley and drag
[Music]
it's funny you say Canadian because
hosers safe after every single sentence
like how's it going and you save more
than hosers it's sounding like an
affectation it sounded like someone told
you to be edgy by using and it's become
your new life you're like what why don't
you guys talk about real issues like the
Armenian Genocide that's what we want to
hear about the the in justices of the
Turks over the years especially the
Young Turks why don't you do a whole
special during her minion History Month
about all the horrible things to do
Armenians have a month because you guys
could fill it up with your horrible
young Turkish crimes okay well of course
he's gonna bring up the Armenian
[Music]
stop it that's it that's embarrassing
comparison this next guest who actually
nicked Apollo last time he was on set he
is a comedy savant nah you can follow
all of his work at compound Mediacom
they have Gavin McGinnis all kinds of
programs they're really blowing it up
Anthony ku Mia thanks for being with us
sir thank you sir
always a pleasure I enjoy your show and
of course your tweets are hilarious the
lioness depends on the day and depends
on whether I support David Duke or not
as I learned that yes have you disavowed
have you disavowed you're not only that
even when I was like mrs. David Dukes
kind of a dirtbag and it was a set up
question why is this hard to build how
dare you disrespect dr. David Duke he's
a doctor dr. David there's no winning
there's no winning with it no no well
okay so speaking of which this is I mean
obviously you you with your show being
we're comedy centric the Hillary health
stuff that just it must be like catnip
for your show the longer this whole
process goes on we've buddy a little
over a year in with this whole campaign
it's been insane and and just when you
think it can't get crazier it gets
crazier and Hillary just you know
collapsing I had a moment of silence the
other day at the exact minute that
Hillary collapsed at Ground Zero we took
a little time out wasn't a piping 74°
where you were yes I was just balmy I
like Hillary heat index when it's 76 and
breezy
the Hillary heat index is 115 what
happened to 84 you kill a guy yeah yeah
quite the trail of bodies around her no
it's it's gotten ridiculous and the way
they try to spin it and the media not
even attempting anymore not even
attempting to come off unbiased they are
in her corner firmly not denying it
anymore and they're unapologetic it's
pathetic and still Trump prevails it's
amazing well if I had a nickel for every
phone up day I've gotten with from CNN
saying Hillary's okay she said so
herself
all day money like every few hours she
had a date
she had a v8 hydrated now splash 4x
refreshments I mean who knew the clinton
body count would actually include
clinton at this point it's we've gotten
that she catches herself and what if she
has the same plot as Vince Foster here's
the deal when we flirt look we didn't
cover it when it was a conspiracy we
were going like okay there might be
something but we do understand it's its
clickbait for a lot of these sites right
wait we ran the one story this week
because it was legitimate and it was
four or five times the traffic so we
have to try and be truthful but here's
the deal they lied about this even if
it's new-mown even though it's pneumonia
they said she was fine Friday so is it
possible she has pneumonia yeah it
stands to reason is it possible they
lied because it's all they know how to
do yes there are so many people that if
they came out on Friday that Friday and
said hey our candidate here has
pneumonia everybody would go oh okay
there would be one person maybe one not
going on really is it the money but for
the most part you would believe it right
with Hillary and that whole organization
over there you cannot believe anything
that comes out of a corner you just
can't do it
and when they said pneumonia I
immediately called BS on it because it
just sounds like another lie to cover up
something that's going on over there
have you ever had pneumonia I have not
but I made fun of Hillary's cough about
a week and a half ago overnight I got a
horrible she's a witch she conjures
she's gonna doll with him you sticking
pins in his yeah pins in it like phlegm
down she's coughing in my my Dollface
bronchitis and I know it's not but it's
relatively similar either I've known it
was pneumonia and they've never done
this there's a mad action typical my dad
my dad had like really bad pneumonia
once that was never part of the that was
never part of the routine no yeah that
whole video of her teetering over while
the Secret Service were eagerly awaiting
the arrival of the vehicle its you see
her legs just being dragged
along the ground there just seems to
have lost her footing on the was a
little weak need know she was out like
Jared talked about not kids you'd you
mentioned this it just looked like
another day at the office for the city
that's what's disturbing there was
happening well it was well it was well
choreographed it looked like they had
drilled for it in the past no longer
shocked or surprised they're just like
oh my job is to hide any cameras from
fainting Hillary over there right one of
those goats that just Teeter over well
you just compare it to the ryan lochte
scenario when Dancing with the Stars
where a guy gets on set and it's an
event right they tackle them there's
this energy and you've got the potential
president the United States not how they
react typically but you're right it's
some listen I have tried to support
Trump where he's right and criticize him
one fair and there is a lot to criticize
I mean you're in New York guy but I've
heard you talk about you're like God you
can't believe Trump says some stuff I
think everyone feels that way about him
sure yes a little is a little kooky yeah
yeah and sometimes I just with her
everything is premeditated and dishonest
with him it stems from thoughtlessness
but sometimes but the comparison like
you said I mean today we have the DNC
leaks and then right away either
something comes out with the Trump
foundation or something is we got it
Brady NC leaks where they're promising
you're promising positions with the post
office if they donate enough to the
party I mean have you been following
this absolutely they they cannot throw
enough distractions out to the people to
try to keep them from reading I as a
matter of fact what's her name the
temporary head of the DNC that was put
in not
Warren that weren't wasserman-schultz
I've confused no out and then they broke
the other woman in she said today she
said I would not recommend reading any
of the WikiLeaks emails because they may
be full of malware so steer clear of
though it's like it's these Hail Mary
attempts at trying to keep people from
finding out what a bunch of degenerates
there are I don't retail his tax
proposal it's a pop up for gay porn just
avoid it
we'll be right back with Anthony ku Mia
of compound Mediacom it's not going to
get better if that's what you're
expecting stage
[Music]
hey you watching the livestream
don't worry to tweet us that's grata at
Nigerian it's a good times
Oh subscribe below yeah doctors are with
Viacom going on all kinds of articles
and more stuff that you see here hey why
you wait brush your teeth in the shower
my favorite comma red and GQ I thought
about that I guess it does
[Music]
all right glad to be back that outro was
my my mother-in-law and apparently found
a right away run the YouTube copyright
she was the Fox which she's like she
looks like Sally Field she's the
sweetest lady yeah with the Fox and a
leopard print leotard never would have
known I just get too comfortable with
myself when I record album we have him
back
compound Mediacom Anthony could mean I'm
sorry had to sit through them that's
okay you got some moves there my friend
well it's pretty it's it's a big selling
point for the program we're talking
about the DNC leaks yeah it is amazing
this is one thing that you don't need to
be a political pundit or talking head to
understand that the the DNC and leftism
right now they always want fewer voices
they always want less transparency I
mean what have you ever heard them say
well let's just let the chips fall where
they may and give the public as much
information as possible it's not a part
of their platform no the transparency
thing really means nothing anymore when
the Obama administration first came in
their whole thing was oh we are going to
be the most transparent administration
ever and Hillary is constantly crowing
about transparency and it's just
transparent it like like a cinderblock
wall there's no seeing anything and they
try to they lie about it I've known
people my whole life that you don't even
have to lie and they do anyway you ever
you talk to somebody to go hey you ever
see that movie and then they go yeah and
you start talking about it you realize
they never saw the movie right and
you're like why didn't you just say you
didn't see it yeah that's how Hillary is
it everything has to be a lie that comes
out of her and her camp right well and
like the hot sauce well I get
technically Obama hired the first [ __ ]
right wasn't it what was the the cabinet
role remember that was a big deal yeah
yes everyone was praising it all right
even I was on read on they're like well
this is bold I was like really I mean
who cares and I think the person turned
out to be crazy right wasn't they're
alive later on am I am i that makes that
makes perfect Z it's that that's what
why are we so hung up on firsts like oh
we had the first black president and now
like every subsequent president ever now
from now on has to be a first
something we need the next president the
first woman president the first Hispanic
president they it can we just please get
back and and and make people comfortable
with just some dumb old white guy in
there right yes that's that's the
takeaway from that they're like first
it's only when it's convenient like
that's the first black president it
sounds the first president to smoke
crack with a terrorist well we don't
even talk about what are you singling
him out because he's black oh my god you
did you did crack because he's black no
because he smoked crack it's um it is it
is tough it is tough right now let me
ask you this so kind of pivoting that
you were talking about the media yeah I
know your friends and a lot of these
people so we have to be careful and
we've talked about this with Nick
DiPaolo but I do feel like now it's
never been more blatant where you see
the the comedy sphere the entertainment
industry but a lot of stand-up comedians
they are just doing the bidding for the
Democratic Party
that's got to tick you off as someone
who's been a part of it for so long I've
never understood why the entertainment
business has this fascination with the
left and you know this time around with
Hillary and they're there promoting her
and trying to get her elected I don't
get it
they're the worst when it comes to
actual freedom of speech which I believe
freedom of expression freedom of speech
is a big part of entertainment and
especially comedy like they are trying
to take the comedic context out of
everything and make it seem like whether
you're a comedian or a surgeon or a
judge it all goes into the same category
you made a joke about this horrible
thing and it doesn't matter they don't
look at it as as comedic context right
everyone is Hitler or this one
misogynistic or homophobia that there's
a context to entertainment and there's a
freedom of expression that we're
supposed to have that the left just
wants eliminated and I don't understand
how people in the entertainment business
want to embrace that it's ridiculous
well particularly like female comedians
I'm I know you you know obviously
Schumer is the biggest name for up to
third and Sarah Silverman and last time
we had you know we talked about this
there there I'm sure they're still your
friends but it has gotten so brine
Dingley annoying that most people I know
who are fans like I can't I can't take
any more every
is talking about rape culture or you
heard Amy Schumer's thing this week
right where she talked about Hillary she
said anyone who says anything bad about
her they're just they're just they're
not informed no one has any reason other
than she's a woman to not like her yeah
she said she never heard anybody say a
bad thing about Hillary that made any
sense
yeah and it's it's that's the left
though they they look at you they'll say
things like oh oh what's the Benghazi
thing and it's like you can't just guess
oh the email thing yes email thing they
say it like just because they're saying
it like that right that you're stupid we
know everything you just hung up on
stupid stuff yeah a good example with
Young Turks he's called me out okay I'll
debate you he's like oh I'm not gonna
debate a guy who thinks at door he's big
Hitler with a socialist it's in the name
like it's absurd anybody's like oh what
a [ __ ] [ __ ] Nazis were socialists
yes yeah
socialist well it's more national it's
like uh it's what we had Sally cone on
this we can god bless her she's really a
nice person she'll have a discussion but
she kept talking about Isis or just kept
saying right wing right wing about zero
freedom and it's like Ryan isn't the
right about less government in your life
and and there it is tyranny I try to put
it on the right and all right has been a
big thing with with Hillary and the rest
of the lefties over there they're trying
to portray like think you know basket of
deplorable right they're trying to
portray so many people in that light
blaming Trump and Trump followers for
the people that follow them right but
you can't possibly blame a Trump because
there is some pretty far right people
that want him to be president right just
as you can't blame Hillary for having a
terrorists dad cheering behind her at
one of our rallies is funny it is funny
or just like just you just wanna have
that in a gift
loop like a morphine drip it is it is it
is it is I do think particular from the
entertainment standpoint you're seeing a
lot of rebound now and we talked with
with Nick about this and he disagreed I
think a lot of people who establish
themselves in comedy a longer time ago
they still have this sort of puritanical
view of it the comedy club scene the
college anywhere in traditional stand-up
comedy now it there really is a barrier
to entry and that's why I think you're
seeing a lot of people just go online
it's changing where they're going the
entertainment industry is not welcoming
to anyone outside of this narrow point
of view have you felt that that shift oh
my god I was I was in it before it
really started being exposed for what it
is I mean I got fired from Sirius XM for
tweeting about me being assaulted by
black I was assaulted I tweeted about it
and I got fired you know that was and to
me I was just like okay it's just gotten
way out of hand if that's what's
happened and then in the two years or a
little over two years that that happened
people started catching on oh this is
what's going on and I'm like yes finally
you're seeing what what happened right
there is a pushback and I'm because I'm
kind of in that circle of people I see
it they're disgusted and they are going
about it themselves now just like I've
had to do here not build my own studio I
don't have a boss that could fire me
anymore right it's because they're
petrified of being thrown with one of
those scarlet letters yeah what are you
an are racist a homophobic misogynistic
they're petrified of getting that label
so they will appease anybody that
complains to them that one of their
employees is a whatever initial they
want to throw on him with that one
comedy that there didn't used to be
words like as persons a Republican but
now it's like you can't be in this and
you're not allowed to be a part of this
if you don't think like with that that's
a big difference whether it's you know
college humor or the Funny or Die you
know the even in the online sphere it is
a witch hunt like oh if there is a
successful just
non-liberal not even conservative
personnel anywhere we have to
all-hands-on-deck assault and I've seen
a lot of people behind the scenes where
we you and I know I'm Way more
conservative than they let on
like I just I can't wait into it they
can't there are so many people in
Hollywood there's those select few that
have literally destroyed their career by
coming out and saying hey I'm a
conservative hey I'm for Trump and then
there's a bunch of other ones that just
are closeted like the old communist days
you don't want to be blacklisted out of
the business so they have to present
themselves as liberals and I think
there's a huge portion that are not they
don't have to be conservative but they
certainly aren't looking at Hillary as
the next Messiah
like we see Streisand or Bette Midler or
any of the other favorites of the gays
come out and say they're kind of
interchangeable in mind it's kind of
like Snowden and Assange Midler's rising
like which one did that one which one
was funny girl
which one lives into the in a gated
house that says what we should be doing
what well yeah that's a good example so
like I go back to a bit but because Amy
Schumer in your state pushed gun cattle
with with unki Chuck here's one thing
for me I think that's a very important
litmus test because if you are a
comedian right now pushing the envelope
in any way you have to be a second
amendment support I mean you know and I
know the kind of threats you get and I
don't mean online drama but dealing with
the FBI you parry I can't imagine it now
it tells me you're not taking any risks
of the commedia doesn't matter how much
blue material you do but you're not
really pissing anyone off would be a
risk if you're willing to ban guns well
as far as Amy Schumer goes and her uncle
Chuckie when when an entertainer has an
opinion and they state their opinion
that's one thing I'm not gonna go off on
oh wow this person thinks says like I
find I like Patton Oswalt trivia our
worlds worlds apart politically and I
get enraged at some of the stuff I read
that he posts on Twitter but I'm friends
with him and he's I think he's very
funny I think he's a conservative and a
lot of a right-wing in a lot of ways she
doesn't real
when you sit there glaring going on
there yes there but he's got opinions
and that's one thing when Amy started
cycling up with Chuck and actually
moving to limit guns to people citizens
that becomes something different and I
cannot go along with something like that
so I have definitely said like I do not
appreciate the fact that amy is trying
to get people's constitutional rights
taken away that is more than an opinion
yeah whoever it is and it removes you
from it if ever you see that person in a
film or you know that's all you're
thinking about you know like and you
can't have it well the worst part is -
is Lena Dunham I mean I find anything
Schumer funny but like you've got Lena
Dunham is it just a talentless amoeba
and I'm like Amy why are you what is
like if there's ever more clearly a
Robin to a Batman it's Lena Dunham
two-shoes I I get Dunham cozying up to
Taylor Swift and Schumer I don't
understand it the other way around I
don't I don't get it does she hang out
the same nightclubs as you guys I don't
get it either yeah you don't want to be
the you don't want to be the girl that
that the guys at the bar at the end of
the night they have to look and be the
wingman and be like well and that's this
whole liberal politically correct that's
a side effect of that whole thing when
when she takes her clothes off and
everybody's like you go girl you're so
brave and beautiful no body shaming know
that and then an attractive girl poses
and scantily-clad they're like oh
disgusting he's just making herself a
piece of meat out there for and every
guy is going no we want to see that one
yeah I know how brave you are we want to
see that girl and the irony is they're
condemning the one thing that knows no
racial boundaries it knows no economic
class the male erection is a variable
beauty whether stick I've said that like
it doesn't care what color you are how
much money happen like that's the sexist
it's not it really is the most fair or
if you just have a bunch of John
Thomases as judges in this country yeah
justice would be blind
Anthony Kamiya compound media thank you
so much sir for being with us in doubt
bluff Duffy back soon
thank you up man thanks a lot absolutely
and that was uh well we'll be back we'll
be back
[Music]
for bragging news a lot Earl of Crowder
I'm Perry Martha let's hit you know
alive as Lauren has restarted her
campaign and stopped in Missouri at its
longest running most famous local ice
cream shop Troy a picture of health will
keep you over us as the story unfolds
[Music]
got my breath there I would never let
you go Jack until I'm slightly
inconvenient than Jenna on my iceberg
stuff I don't know just it was bad it
was good I don't know there wasn't any
reason to toss him into the ocean when
he was frozen to the raft he wasn't
going anywhere oh no his little five
year old Jordan theater Dan the booby
seen the promise with that I forever
knew Kate Winslet as the booby lady you
know I was convinced as a kid that she
must have just she must been brewing her
bill rubber suit I was as a kid I was so
naive to think never grenades you know I
think it must be that's a really
convincing rubber suit no Anthony Kamiya
was great to have him of course everyone
listening terrestrially or if you're
watching on youtube you can subscribe on
iTunes all of the Young Turks videos
that you've seen in the commercial
breaks by the way they're hidden across
YouTube right now so we did an interview
with Gavin Lauren southern sargon of
akkad and one with yours truly and there
might are there might be some more real
quick I have this up on my screen
Harvard scientists were paid it turned
out to push the fattest bad myth by
conflict of interest with those making
money off of sugars the sugar industry
industry paid prestigious Harvard
scientists to publish research saying
that fat particularly saturated fat was
the key to heart disease turns out that
in moderate amounts it's fine and sugar
is actually a lot worse for you than
they let on here's the damned you big
sugar who think people who write always
say big sugar what's really important is
this was only able to get through and be
so pervasive because of the
environmental lobby also synonymous back
then with a vegetarian the vegan Lobby
who were very very adamantly against any
animal products and in fact so they were
all too happy and complicit to be on
board with oh okay let's vilify
saturated fat and switch just to
hydrogenated vegetable oils so all that
stuff that you don't like the
hydrogenated oils that McDonald used to
use tell at least use beef lard
an environment that you know vegetarians
environmentalist were mad about that and
so there was collusion here here's the
point whenever people
say well it's settled science and they
show you a bunch of government funded
studies I'm not saying that science is
flawed science isn't but the execution
can be people are flawed so this idea
that science is the endgame if there's
some kind of consensus from government
employees whether it's saturated fat
which we know to be false whether it's
this idea that a one degree increase
over the next century will destroy
mankind on earth as we know it so we
need to send the co2 protocol and gave
over trillions of dollars to
international governing bodies um
the execution of science can absolutely
be tainted it can absolutely be
perverted and that brings us back to
this idea what's the takeaway um we're
talking about this the did you know the
truth you don't have to take the you
don't have to go to the extreme for it
to matter we're talking with Sally cone
about Islam you know we don't just have
to talk about Isis burn extended
versions there's an extended debate yep
online la doors clatter calm Friday
morning whenever you're listening to
this burning Christians alive in cages
is terrible absolutely Isis is terrible
but guess what
in Turkey in Egypt in the UAE where
women are required several witnesses to
rape otherwise they're jailed where
women aren't allowed to drive without
their husbands saying so where a pause
death for apostates is very common in
the Islamic world that's enough not you
don't need Isis Islam is enough Islam is
bad enough the same thing with Hillary
Clinton we were talking about this
Hillary Clinton they lied about the
pneumonia they lied about the health
issues that's enough you don't need her
to have AIDS or Parkinson's you don't
need her to have a body double they lied
that's enough and sometimes the truth is
far more potent than a lie it's far more
effective than a lie and that comes back
to your worldview we're talking with
economics does your worldview allow for
the value the principle that hey you
know what regardless of all of this yeah
that would create some more clicks yeah
that would create some more web traffic
yeah a body double would be a more would
be a more sweet story to have right it'd
be it'd be more juicy but does the truth
matter and and the beauty is that right
now with was the argument that we're
making the truth is enough the truth is
convincing if you're not desensitizing
people to the truth by viewing all these
things just
rape culture mm-hmm rape is really bad
it's bad enough one in three women one
in four women are not raped if it's one
in ten if it's one in 20 if it's one in
40 which is far more likely depending on
the the references he use that's bad
enough that's bad enough you don't need
to lie about it and so what happens like
Jared said which was a good point you
desensitize people to rape you
desensitize people to Islam the only
reason Islamist is able to come come in
as a Trojan horse at the back door right
now is because you have left us gone
well not all Muslims are burning people
alive no but of the vast majority of
Muslims do support apostasy laws or some
sort of grossly violating of human
rights Sharia law that's enough
well you know Hillary Clinton doesn't
have Parkinsons so I don't know it
doesn't matter it's enough that she lied
about the pneumonia that they lied to
the press for a long time what the email
situation another one people going oh
then Hillary Clinton what did she send
she didn't send anything that was a real
national security threat even if so it
doesn't matter it's enough that she
broke the law
it's enough that she knowingly went
against protocol it's enough that she
lied under oath but when people try to
go with something bigger and build it
into something that it's not and used
the conspiracy theory again that matters
with the worldview the values the
principles where you say you know what
I'm not going to do that because my
safeguard is truth but there's the added
benefit the truth is enough you don't
the michaelbay the truth you don't have
to Michael Bay bigger better more
explosions more City destruction one
would argue that Pearl Harbor in and of
itself was a fascinating enough story I
didn't need Josh Hartnett's nipples they
weren't required sometimes the truth is
enough
and and you see this a lot on the right
and the left but I'm particularly
disappointed to see it on the right
where people just take something that's
untrue and run with it because it's a
better story or they know that's a trend
that they can tap into listen you should
tap into trends you should be relevant
that's all great but the truth does
matter and we've talked about why the
truth matters and that should be first
and foremost but the beaut
is here in the long run truth is more
effective the truth
as it relates to most of the issues now
whether it's immigration whether it's
terrorism whether it's Hillary Clinton
the truth is more effective than the lie
and in a long-term your credibility
won't suffer truth is better than a lie
talk to you next week maybe never daily
[Music]
you